Chris Cuomo has some moves okay fine
Chris Cuomo has some dad moves the CNN
anchor showed off his skills in a video
posted to his 17 year old daughter
Bella's tick-tock that's Chris totally
video bombing his daughter while she's
dancing to a viral tik tok mash-up of
Ke$ha Megan the stallion and Rihanna
[Music]
[Music]
seriously those are some grade-a dad
moves random kicking check shoulder
shimmying check and a little snapping
thrown in for good measure
check check check yeah those are the
kind of moves that were made for
embarrassing your teenage daughter and
it's not the first time Chris has tested
out some dad choreo on tik-tok that was
Chris in February doing his best to keep
up with Bella
[Music]
of course the 49 year old TV journalist
was diagnosed with coronavirus back in
March I tested positive scared yes as
you might imagine but he continued to
work while he was under quarantine from
his wife and three kids streaming his
show from his basement so yeah I've had
a I've had a fever you've had a fever
but 102 103 103 plus that wouldn't quit
and it was like somebody was beating me
like a pinata
once Chris was on the mend Bella shared
her attempt hanging out with her dad on
tick-tock - my dad has corona but he's
gonna be okay he's actually doing really
well right now but I just got this
outfit because I wanted to hang out with
him today and see what he thinks my new
outfit
did you turn your volume up in April
Chris's wife Christina and their
fourteen-year-old son Mario tested
positive for kovat 19 Christina now has
Kovac she is now positive according to
Chris Bella stepped up and took care of
her little sis 10 year old Carolina
while the rest of the fam was under
quarantine at the time Chris's brother
governor of New York Andrew Cuomo said
the whole experience might be a good
thing for their kids
you want to talk about growing up a
little bit and seeing reality a little
bit Bella will step up so it's it's all
going to be fine well Bella had a little
fun with that moment on tick tock -
Bella will step up so it's it's all
going to be fine hey don't be fine and
it turns out it really is fine last week
Christina shared this pic of her kiddos
on Instagram revealing Mario had
recovered from the virus
people have been feeling really
debilitated by this virus mentally et
recently caught up with Christina who
opened up about her experience with the
virus no one is at first to getting this
you can get it anywhere
it's how I you know come to realize I
got it at home you know I got it home
because Chris got it somewhere out there
and in the world whether it was you know
he was just commuting to and from to the
office to do the show and that's it so
at some point you know it found him and
and that was that and we're all
vulnerable to it so we just have to do
our best to stay you know keep our
social distance stay home and really
take care of yourselves now's the time
more than ever we don't have our health
or nothing matters there's no economy
there's nothing that that will survive
survive this
[Music]